各位同学又见面了
今天分享的内容是歌词
画面感与文字情绪之创作技巧
记得画面感
文字情绪
文字也可以有表情
也可以有情绪的
接下来我会用两首歌来当做一个范例
跟大家解释
其中一首叫爱在西元前
这首歌比较有趣的是
我一样是写给一个女生的
而且是跟倒带同一个女生
这个今天等于是说告白时间就对了
那那时候我还在追求他
让我带他去看美索不达米亚展
两河流域的美索不达米亚展
看了之后就觉得哇好特别
因为我很喜欢那种不同的文化的那种冲击
就是哇谢谢文字
没看过
像那种古巴比伦的那种巨型的石碑
就觉得很震撼哇
不同的文明对文字的那种
应该讲说发展的途径不一样
这就很深深的吸引着我
那时候刚好周同学呃
爱在先前的曲好了给我
我几天都没动笔
然后看完那个两河流域的美索不达米亚展
回来之后就很有感觉
然后我就开始去写
写完之后呢
我就放在他的桌上
然后没多久我们就变成男女朋友了
就是这样子
那后来就但还是分手了
因为倒带嘛
就是这个是交往初期的歌
倒带是结束的歌
然后最后还遇到个女生
那个就是真命天女的
后来就就结婚了
OK就这样子
女朋友没有很多哦
解释一下好
那我现在分享一下爱
在西元前
大家可以稍微看一下那个视频
像这首爱在西元前
本来一开始的歌名叫美索不达米亚
又觉得美索不达米亚很酷
你知道吗
就是一个好像异域的神秘的古国
然后后来发现说不对
他是整段都是名词地名这个区域嘛
两河之间的一个区域
一个平原
就觉得好像哪里不对劲
左思右想
后来改成爱在西元前
这个感觉就是有个距离
有个距离产生美感
因为爱在西元前
西元前的意思是2000年前就觉得哦好特别
那这首歌写的时候呢
里面就很有画面感
因为我看完一个展览
然后大概念一下给大家听
就是古巴比伦王颁布了汉谟拉比法典
刻在黑色的玄武岩
距今已3700多年
这首歌发表的时候
很多朋友啊就是跟我讲说哇这个歌词好酷哦
但是我跟他讲说
前面两个是历史的叙述句
而是古巴比伦王颁布了汉谟拉比法典
刻在黑色的玄武岩
距今3700多年
这个叙述据跟唐贞观元年
然后什么黄河泛滥
什么民不聊生一样的啊
它它是历史的叙述句
重点是我第二行就把整个画面的结构拉回来了
我第二行写你在橱窗前凝视碑文的字眼
我却在旁静静欣赏你那张我深爱的脸
这个就是把整个场景拉回来了
如果各位同学要写这种国民的这种歌词
记得不要从头到尾在描述场景
这是不对的
你不是在写一本历史书
也不是在拍纪录片
一定要有情感的东西进来才能感动的
因为歌是给人听的
不是历史的记载
再下来祭司神殿征战
弓箭是谁的
从前前面四句哦
全部都是画面感
喜欢在人潮中
你只属于我的那画面
又把他拉回来了
正如我前面铺垫了很多的名词
画面感没有关系
情绪又被我拉回来了
有时候画面感在前面
情绪在后面
有时候情绪在前面
画面感在后面
然后
副歌给你个啊
今天毒狗
如果有个人歌词写给你的爱
那这谁都能写吗
给我的爱
给你的幸福
给你的保护
这这个是太寻常的用语
重点是后面接什么
给你的爱写在西元前
深埋在美索不达米亚平原
几十个世纪后出土
发现泥板上的字迹依然清晰可见
它历史的结构又回来了
就说你去创作的时候
记得要经营故事线
画面感
要交错的使用
不能通篇都是名词
通篇都是画面感
然后第二段的副歌
第一句是记忆点
我没有改
我给你的爱写在西元前
深埋在美索不达米亚平原
用楔形文字刻下了永远那已风化千年的誓言
一切又重演
记得歌词创作就是这么有趣
等到你掌握它的诀窍
他的技巧
他的空间
他的可能性
任何的题材都是可以化成一篇篇的歌词
重点是你要懂得变化取舍
交错地使用
再来我们再分享一首威廉古堡
威廉古堡是我第一次拿到金曲奖的创作
那一年很特别
就是同时入围的三首就是爱在西元前
上海1943
我会连古堡名额给人家占了一半
那时候我很害怕
你知道吗
在台下的时候
我想说
这次入围就是六个名额
然后我居然给他占一半
万一上台的不是我怎么办
我就很忐忑不安
脚都在发抖
后来哦终于上台了
就就是松了一口气好
接下来就分享这首威廉古堡
在之前的课堂有分享过
本来叫吸血鬼
快上网去google发现吸血鬼有人用了
然后找关键字
所以这首歌跟爱在西元前不一样
爱在西元前是最自私最保险的命名法
那威廉古堡是关键字
就像倒带一样是关键字
所以秘密是可以很活泼的
藤蔓植物爬满了伯爵的坟墓
古堡里一片荒芜
长满了杂草的泥土
看伯爵跟古堡藤蔓植物
画面感很浓稠
就是整个吸血鬼就呼之欲出
好像快出来了
然后第二行不会骑扫把的胖女巫
用拉丁文念咒语
啦啦啦呜
有时候鸽子你用叠句没有关系
要用得恰如其分
她养的黑猫笑起来像哭啦啦啦呜
用水晶球替人占卜
就说女巫嘛算命的嘛
然后水晶球
这些都是在这个时空背景合理出现的视觉画面
让你去堆叠它
它整个场景的空间感就很强
接下来我用的语汇是比较不常见的
语法的结构不常见
为什么不常见
你看他说下午三点的阳光射进教堂的角度
能知道你前世是狼人还是蝙蝠
狼人或者是蝙蝠
还好它就是两个名词
问题是下午三点的阳光
下午三点的阳光
基本上几万首歌也不会去用
接下来的歌词他就进入了歌的名字
古堡主人威廉二世
满脸的络腮胡
习惯在吸完血后开始打呼
古堡主人叫威廉吗
威廉是很很旧派的英文名
知道吧
你不用DAVID吧
你你古堡主人大卫就很奇怪了
或或者是温森就很奇怪了
就说你既然锁定了那个时空背景
连这个小细节都要注意
就说那个年代用威廉是比较老派的命名法
那就合理了
然后接下来的歌词是管家是一只会说法语
举止优雅的猪
诸位
但是我刻意把这个猪变成优雅
因为他说法语
因为法语曾经在欧洲的某个年代
是贵族间的通用语嘛
然后再来就是拥有一双蓝色眼睛的凯萨琳公主
专吃有ab血型的公老鼠
那反差凯撒琳公主很漂亮哦
蓝色眼睛哦
但是它吃老鼠
而且还挑血型
然后猪却是举止优雅
因为你要反差才有趣
因为这首歌的结构就是天马行空
你让凯撒琳公主举止优雅
让那只猪去吃老鼠就太合理了太合理了
副歌是恍恍惚惚
是谁的脚步
银制茶壶装蟑螂
蜘蛛恍恍惚惚
其实是叠句的
我刚才讲叠句
叠句是重复的句子
可能啦啦啦呼呜呜呜都可以
III都可以
他有时候会让歌词有点亲切感
你不见得要塞满了有意义的句子
记得变化变化很重要
我是说所有的句子都很深刻
都很隽永
都别人没用过
然后精心的去雕琢文字的那种深刻
不需要这个时间点需要叠句
你就让他拉拉拉
甚至有些歌的副歌整段都给你
啦啦啦呜呜呜都有过
记得变化是创作的最核心的价值
好
继续介绍一下富哥辛辛苦苦
全家怕日出
他们是吸血鬼家族
全家都怕日出
白色蜡烛温暖了空屋
然后第二遍的副歌一样
恍恍惚惚是谁的脚步
字句都一样
客厅壁炉零下的温度
壁炉记得壁炉只有北方才有
特别是欧洲
我整个场景就是古堡
就是威廉的那地图出现的非常的合理
就是去经营文字的时候
时空感
画面感都要兼顾
这样子的创作才是一个全方位的创作
而不是几句漂亮
然后突然跳了一个画面感
然后有几句很疏离
很白话
很浅显
不对的
你要白话就白话
到底歌词不是不能白话
有些舞曲轻松的歌
整个看都是很浅显白话
那又那又怎么样
跳舞的很开心
这个歌的核心价值让人家放松
是让人家跳舞用的
所以他不是去玩文字的结构美
像中国风的歌词某种程度需要
但是有些舞曲电音的歌就不需要创作的时候
一定要记得歌词要配上曲的画面是一致的
不要说这个旋律是很很开心的
你填上很悲伤的词句
纵使那个悲伤的词句再怎么美都是不对的
就像说你一个年轻人
明明你的五官
你的年龄是属于阳光热情的
你的举止也是阳光热情的
可是却穿了一套所有的长袍马褂
实在感觉也错字了
然后掉线也不对了
除非是走秀吧
走秀那种走当代艺术路线的
你可以故意影射什么东西吗
那你可以这么做
那基本上不能这么做
因为创作还是有个规范
这首歌就是这样子去创作
那创作的当下还是比较电玩的感觉
整个空间天马行空
比较偏电玩的感觉
像这样子去挑战不同文明的故事结构
会让你的创作类比更丰富更多元
而不是脑海里面只装东方的东西
这样子的一种创作上的那种跳跃是很过瘾的
因为创作就是要挑战
而且挑战成功过后
你是会有很有成就感的
那西方的那种文明对我来讲是个很珍贵的比对
为什么我一直很喜欢不同文明的激荡
像之前西方有经历过工业革命
也因此他的月季跟东方是不同系列的
我可以这样子跟大家分享一个观点
就是说西方的乐器属于工业文明
那东方的乐器属于农业文明
就说他们有敲响乐
编制多庞大
他们可能是八世纪就很完整了
那是八世纪
我还在清朝
工业革命的养分促使他乐器的一个发展
像萨克斯风
法国号这种铜管乐器
没有工业文明的支撑
这样子的乐器是做不出来的
像我们的传统乐器
可是横笛洞箫
琵琶古筝
古琴这些音乐的那个音量
它的渗透性其实没有西方来的强
他们的钢琴
他们的弦乐团
但是无妨啊
谁说世界上地球上只能有一种声音
你也应该想
还好有中国的存在
还好有中华文明的存在
我们提供了听觉上不同的响应
他的比对是有趣的
你这边的交响乐弦乐团啊
我们那种编制浩瀚的庞大的气势的
我们没办法像我们这样子的乐器的编排
虽然不用所谓的红尾巴或是气势惊人吧
那谁说听觉一定要这样子
你听久了会有压力吧
那我觉得像我们这样的
东方文明情调的那种乐器
古筝搭配横笛洞箫
古琴合奏出来的那样子的东方特色
也是你西方所没有的
人类的文明本来就是互补的
这种反差让我们的生活更有趣
比如说我前几堂的课程
不是又拿了一本新华字典吗
那你想想看哦
因为我们中国的文字是方块字
是单音节
是表意文字
所以呢一旦有新的词汇
我们是没办法音译的
为什么我们不是像那种牛津英文词典
它每一个新的概念出来就造一句新的词
还是拼音文字啊
拼音文字可以这样子啊
当这个社会进展到某个程度
需要新的语汇的时候
他就造了一个新的字
我们没有办法
但是没有关系
吴敏有自己的解决办法
吴敏会自己找到出路
我们怎么解决呢
我们造词我们不增加次的数量
他们造字
我们造词像网络网
蜘蛛网的网
身体的脉络的络
任督二脉络
脉络的弱
我们把网跟络合在一起
就解决了电晶体
电本来就有水晶的晶
身体的体本来就有诶
我们把电晶体三个字合起来就解决问题了
所以我们照此他们造字
我们质的总量没有多
但是我们池在丰富
在变化
这个就是不同文明间互相激荡的一个乐趣
我觉得说这样子的乐趣会丰富了我们的生活
文化是丰富了我们生活内涵的一个要素
那各位同学这堂课很特别
除了歌词创作扎实的训练之外
我会分享其他领域不同的事物
会让你的视野更加的辽阔
这世界上不是只有我们
不是只有一种文化
不是只有一种可能性
那回到文化的议题
就是说文化你怎么去理解这个词汇
最简单一言以蔽之的说法
就是文化就是翻译间流失的东西
什么叫发音间流失的东西
我举例来讲
可能像柳宗元的江雪
千山鸟飞绝万径人踪灭
孤舟蓑笠翁独钓寒江雪
天呐
居然有个民族
他的文字系统可以这么的整齐
然后他这么的对仗
还有韵脚
却包含了很多的意境
这是西方文明办不到的
这个就是文化
文化是什么
文化就是翻译间流失的东西
千山鸟飞绝万径人踪灭
你怎么翻译成英文了
他的对上美就不见了吗
千山对万径嘛
就是很多条山路叫万径嘛
你对不到
然后呢
孤舟蓑笠翁独钓寒江雪
孤舟蓑笠翁独钓独跟孤这种对仗这种意境
一个人哦
整个画面感你可以想象成一幅画
大量大量的留白
一条江上只有一个老翁
穿着蓑衣在钓江里面的鱼
这个说明了什么东西呢
说明了很多的意境是可以体现在文字的
文字是可以让人家有画面感的
歌词也是你的歌词是有力量
让人家看到歌词不需要借由音乐就有画面感
等到音乐进来就更加温
等到歌手演绎的时候
散播出去的时候
OK那你整个故事线清楚了
整个歌词的布局跟遣词用语
都是focus在一件事物上
让人家听歌的时候
脑海中就有画面感
情绪就共鸣
整个疗愈的心情就进去了
这个是歌词创作的一个最高的
追求记得今天的标题歌词
画面感与文字情绪的创作技巧
什么叫画面感
就场景结构空间
但是你不能只有画面感
你只有画面感会变成什么摄影作品
就是一幅一幅单个很漂亮的摄影作品
站在那里
但是他没有影像化
他说没有流通
但是我们歌词是依附着音乐才有生命的
所以呢你的歌词一定要借由音乐
借由歌手的传唱去流通
所以呢写歌词的时候要兼顾到客观的角度
因为客观才能引起最大的共鸣性
切记哦
之所以把歌词画面感跟文字情绪一起讲
就说这两个都是歌词里面的要素
不能只有画面感
只有画面感的话
整个情绪是一块一块的
所有的点线面一块一块
但是你的文字情绪进来了
他就连成线
等到配上曲歌手传唱的时候就变成面
记得点线面才是一个完整对歌词把握的诠释
我们这堂课还会跟大家分享
各种的创作的可能性跟条件跟技巧
这么多元的授课内容
会让你的视野更辽阔
看事物的角度更客观客观
容易引起共鸣
写歌绝对不能主观思才可以主观
因为我们写歌的对象是给人家听的
不是自己看的开心的
所有的创作就一定有发表欲
你的歌切记是要发表的
是要散播出去的
所以呢你必须用客观的角度去形容事物
去形容感情
然后在这么多类别的课程中去丰富了你的视野
跟你看事物的不同角度
最终记得行
说出自己作品的识别度
也就是风格
这个很重要
记得哦
同学们每一集都要做个小功课
做个小笔记
这个会对你有所帮助的